je voudrais vous convaincre de ma totale
détermination à combler toutes les
failles ou lacunes relevant tant des
pratiqu professionnelles que de la
loi encore une fois bon chaque
infraction chaque viol chaque féminicide
euh est un échec pour toute notre notre
société
euh mais chaque
plainte transmise au parquet
est en soit un progrès et si la justice
n'est pas saisie je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est une évidence mais parfois
il faut redire les évidences si la
justice n'est pas sédie naturellement
elle ne peut pas
intervenir alors la justice n'a pas d'a
priori dans notre pays souvent lorsque
les procédures sont classées bah
disons-le c'est faute de preuve pas
comment faut d'identification de
l'auteur tout cela c'est une constante
c'est tout un système probatoire c'est
c'est l'état de droit c'est le
fonctionnement judiciaire tel
que tel qu'il doit être consacré et ça
ne veut pas dire que les faits n'ont pas
eu lieu mais simplement qu'ils n'ont pas
pu être démontré en justice et il nous
faut inciter les victimes à déposer
plainte le plus vite possible pour cela
éducquons nos enfants et tous les
adultes identifier toutes les situations
de violence sexuelle car nous disposons
je pense d'un vaste arsenal
législatif pour y répondre